mesdames et messieurs bienvenue à 2/5
rim dernier épisode de la sorcière
dormantes ce jeu de rôle en cinq
épisodes donc qu'on aura fait sur cette
chaîne youtube
enfin cinquième et dernier ou peut-être
pas dernier on en reparlera de ça à la
fin en tout cas je vais faire comme à
chaque fois vous allez avoir des
timecode ici qui correspondent à des
moments précis
présentation des personnages résumé des
épisodes précédents et le début de cette
cinquième partie tu vas manger des chips
[Musique]
car oui on peut dans les épisodes sont
en public avec un public déchaîné
mesdames et messieurs j'accueille
maintenant les joueurs
non
là j'ai plus de moi parce que je jure le
tout le temps ok bienvenue pour ce
cinquième épisode est ce que vous
souvenez bien du 4e n'ont d'ailleurs
c'est pas le cinquième qui le quatrième
qui nous intéresse le plus mais on le
sait le troisième puisque on a remarqué
que les épisodes s'alterner un peu d'un
militaire mettre le main le 3 et 5 c
dans la réalité c'est bien résumé son
redire ce que j'ai dis toujours dire de
deux manières différentes
mais je suis le gardien sanchez les
numéros impairs à tanger et 1d pour voir
si tu expliquer ils n'ont qu'à nous on
fait comme d'habitude vous allez vous
présenter rapidement on va commencer ce
coup ci on va faire lors damas nous
allons commencer par célia bonsoir célia
et surtout pas finir par c'est bien
c'est toujours le truc le plus clair
avec une pression va être derrière moi
donc célia éclaireuses 22 ans
chasseuse à mes heures perdues à
deschamps rat des champs
pour l'instant ça n'a pas du tout été
utile donc j'espère que ça va l'être
pour aller sous terre ne font toujours
pas donc voilà par contre je vois dans
le noir et sa sous terre ça peut être
pratique ce qu'on appelle donc une 2d
nouveau
du coup levé la main et anciens
nous avons également max veut alors je
suis amoureux il a une grosse épreuve à
chelsea je dis toujours la même chose se
récuser un truc mais je suis très
sensible c'est qu'il a 7 voilà que à sa
présentation oui nous avons également
doc seven alliage wilburn voilà je fais
partie de la guilde des voleurs
je suis très expérimenté je suis
particulièrement experts de mai doit
d'abord imité confirme transforme des
trucs là j'ai perdu
[Musique]
généralement ce métier est quand même
pour ouvrir les portes voilà non mes
petits voleurs rat des villes pour aller
avec le rat des champs et puis attaque
sournoise mais non c'est bien découvre
ton personnage
nous avons également vérino alias dorine
à bord de navires et mathieu des
templiers exactement dorine
dorine qui est clairement là une
formation académique sa star academy
plus ou moins elle est partie la
première semaine donc on se souvient pas
d'elle mais les morts mais oui et oui
oui tu n'entends rien de spécial qui est
vraiment vraiment l'hymne de dorine m
quatre épisodes qui l'a tant est qu'il
en ait ou alors que normalement il a une
compétence supplémentaire qui est elle
nous avons également céline h moi je
voudrais quand même commencé par dire
quelque chose sur ce que n'a pas fait
connaître
et voilà tout le drame du personnage de
sokhna qui dans sa biographie elle le
dit je n'ai pas vraiment eu d'enfance
non mais c'est vrai les mails à 24 ans
les personnes qui n'a du coup voilà ce
qui fait que maintenant à 31 ans elle
envoie du pâté les magiciennes et puis
alors elle aime bien le feu et et la
pierre alors connaît bien les murs
porteurs et la pyrotechnie c'est son
délire et puis à l'appui sans volonté et
puis elle également
aux compétences informations académique
et puis elle également qu'alors on
enchaîne avec résumé des épisodes
précédents
pressé de résumer très rapide qu'est ce
qui s'est passé à la fin de l'épisode iv
est ce que vous en souvenez c'était en
temps réel il ya moins d'une heure
étrangement je me souviens plus de celui
d'avant mois grosso modo vous avez
découvert le moyen de passer la fameuse
porte vous aviez découvert dans
l'auberge là vous avez commencé à
exploser à exploser rien du tout
explorez le sanctuaire et que vous avez
découvert qualité la nature de votre
ennemi et surtout comment le combat et
oui parce que hélas pour eux vous êtes
parce qu'on a retenu un beau de pouvoir
le dormeur doit se réveiller une phrase
que nous avons le devoir utiliser
pendant l'acte un fil hélas pour vous
vous êtes retrouvé de réversion o'leary
despars billets à owni et maintenant
c'est oui on lire dans les rêves tu
fermes n'étaient pas déjà fait dans les
rêves des rats lâché un truc alors là
combien de réalité en tout il y en a
deux ou trois désormais vous êtes
emprisonné prêts à être livrés la
sorcière dormantes souvenez vous vous
êtes réveillés il aurait on est a
renchéri
vous vous réveillez une fois de plus
sans savoir si vous êtes vraiment en
train de rêver aussi tout cela est bien
réelle vous reconnaissez les lieux
autour de vous il s'agit de la chambre
que vous avez découverte après la fête
du village
lorsque vous aviez suivi cyr hall audrin
qui conduisait dort masse vers son
destin et vous êtes affalé sur le sol
jetés comme des sacs au milieu de la
pièce à mesure que vous reprenez
connaissances vous constatez que vous
n'êtes pas seuls wadhams heureusement le
défend chez nous mais de nombreux
villages et donc armer de pic à glace et
vous lance des regards de mauvais bien
entendu vos aimables hôtes ont pris la
précaution de vous lier les mains et de
vous dépouiller de votre équipement
quand tout à coup la troupe hausse il
s'écarte laissant le passage à sir paul
houde rhin qui vous 3 2 où le regard
lourd de mépris à vous voilà réveillé je
ne sais pas ce que vous avez fait j'en
ai à vous voilà réveillé je ne sais pas
ce que vous avez fait mais on peut dire
que vous avez attiré l'attention de
notre dame des songes préparez vous elle
sera bientôt là on a vu des mouvements
nous ample connaissance avec vous puis
sir laudrin semble regarder derrière
vous et tout à poullan ce merdier
montrez-vous utile pour une fois vérifié
qu'elle vient de nos invités sont bien
serré quelqu'un veut faire verdier quel
est ton prénom c'est une spéciale michel
alors tu assieds toi juste ici mais
comme ça tu seras à portée de main pour
moi sergent mardi et rendez vous utile
pour une fois et vérifier les liens voir
s'ils sont bien serré
gratuité alors passez 68e' qui il est
vraiment est ce que tout se passe bien
sûr jean verdier c'est bien attaché oui
c'est ici que vous aviez vu de toute
manière à l'époque dans l'épisode 3
halls audrin emmené dorment associe que
les gens qui regardent des vidéos qui
s'en souviennent
mais oui c'est pas vous donc voilà vous
êtes ici que faites vous mais on est
toujours entouré de gens avec des pics
où ils sont tous la banane et quelques
beaux gosses viens de vous décrire
toujours être super subtil je parle mais
je fais quoi je donne un mélange de
faire ce qu on ne serait pas dans la
zone située à wawa lors on dit le
dormeur doit sauver il faut il attendre
qu'elle soit la nôtre mais ça mais
peut-être que si les dormeurs sa veille
il va se passer est ce que vous tentez
rescue tenté mais vire à gauche
maintenant vous tentez ça plutôt
d'accord c'était médicaux pour les lieux
ils apparaissent bien de me dire dit le
dormeur doit se réveiller le village
voisin des villageois s'approche de toi
te donne un bâton vous a dit ne pas
parler non plus parlante
14h20 elle doit chuter concernant les
personnes qui viennent de chuchoter et
ça se propage aux autres parce que c'est
plus simple
une sensation étrange s'empare de vous
alors que vous récitez se montra votre
vision se trouble
comme si vous étiez en train de voir
double et vous voyez vraiment deux
chambres deux fois la même chambre
et pourtant elles sont toutes les deux
différentes il ya celle où vous vous
trouvez actuellement avec all audrin et
celle que vous avez exploré la vaisselle
avec les codes avec les cadavres sur sur
le sur les sites dans des pierres deux
réalités qui se superposent votre
cerveau à tout le mal possible à faire
le tri entre ce qui est réel et ce qui
ne l'est pas mais vous comprenez vous
êtes à présent dans les deux endroits à
la fois attachée et des mines ici au sol
dans ce cas semble être depuis votre
arrivée à espérer une hallucination
collective provoquée par la dormeuse
mais vous êtes aussi libre et en armes
là bas dans le monde réel quoique
allongé dans la même position sur le sol
néo lodra ni verdier ne sont présents
dans cette autre chambre celle que vous
avez visité la veille
il n'y a que les cadavre momifié des
endormis mais cette vision est très
rapide et bien vite l'autre chambre
celle de cette réalité là se brouillent
et disparaît et vous n'avez plus que la
vision avec les gens avec des pics on a
dit le truc qui on a aperçu l'autre
notre réalité mais on n'est pas allé
venant des revenus on n'était pas c'est
ça donc si on chuchote on aperçoit si on
parle fort on fait piquer les tétons
résumé est ce qu'on sera prêt pas venu
alors
bon du coup on avait quoi comme option
nous c'était ça ou alors tu essaies de
propos télé bien ouais on essaie de se
libérer des lire mes yeux c'est vrai on
est entouré de pique et alors que vous
faites ça le sergent verdier respecte
vos liens comme l'a demandé aux le drame
de côté je pense que la réponse est bien
donner un là on va reçu sauter pourquoi
est ce que tu peux dire ça dans son
oreille métaphores et coupent pas bien
fils de [ __ ] comme seven c'était une
arme non méthodes et des tâches temps
est fini où leurs noms pour l'instant on
n'est pas des tâches et asymétrique et
on a oui le bilan de la semaine
il suffit au mollet village bon internet
tous en même temps on le fera déclare
que la dormeuse est sur le point
d'arriver
la dormeuse est sur le point d'arriver
le dimanche en une musique envoûtante
aulnoy qui provient du couloir est que
de plus en plus forts de plus en plus
présent de plus en plus envoûtante
à partir de ce moment les villageois se
coincent à se chauffer il se moque
ouvertement des joueurs qui vont se
faire défoncer
bien qu'il ait un dernier comme des
simpson aa c'est simplement que ça et là
verdier est passé derrière le seul
villageois qui se trouvait entre vous et
la porte est
le kata soudain il se redresse lui
envoie un coup de pied précis d'une
professionnalité incroyable dans le
journalisme en france analyse main c'est
vrai mais ce procès
cette réalité c'est dans les mêmes mots
salon des réalités on a quand même des
pédiluves de villageois saidal par terre
maintenant vous tient qu'à vous n'avez
qu'à soi pourrait agir qu'est ce que
vous faites c'est pas qu'on vive et
l'aviron comme derrière vous aujourd'hui
la norvège gratitude l'indien refermer
la porte derrière vous by canon
barricadons ton tour in china variés des
perroquets pas fait le professionnaliser
incroyable tu es verdier là qui vous
parle des petits amis ce merdier
je vous invite à me suivre dans la scène
d'une heure j'ai stocker vos armes et
vos équipements là vous allez pouvoir
tous venez s'écoule argent nous aider
c'est sympa mais c'est une excellente
question voulait pas y aller on aura
bien un truc parce que j'ai vraiment
compris ce qui se passait on peut pas
laisser faire ça moi
bizarrement je suis le seul à pas avoir
été atteint par les charmes de la
dormeuse des chauves-souris l'oeil mais
ça va moi ça va eux sont passés un petit
peu fou mais moi je moi c'est bon ça m'a
vraiment gerini j'ai rien on va dépêcher
je vous jure c'est peut-être la donne je
connais pas pourquoi j'ai fait des
chauves souris comme par ci par là elles
deux hommes arrêtés à l'envers ok vous
rentrez et vous récupérez vos affaires
en fait pendant pendant que vous
récupérez lui le verdict continue qui
fait et va pas être content parce qu'on
va pas être content c'est sarko non il
vous dit je pense que je vais payer cher
pour ce que je viens de faire mais il
faut faire vite
les champions et elles vont pas tarder
les autres ont perdu le contrôle pas moi
moi ça va vraiment ça vaut bien
m j'ai hâte d'y être
ça ressemble un foutu cochera sauf que
le problème c'est qu'il ya pas moyen sur
l'abeille et le dormeur doit se
réveiller août une encore meilleure
il vient de dire qu'à personnes qui se
réveille je n'aime pas exactement
pourquoi pas mais voici le lien pour
voir le diaporama doit ce rêve
l'animation comme tout à l'heure tous se
retrouvent les les visions se
superposent et tu vois
l'autre l'autre par attac a atteint par
le parti on est en flip là on est dans
la pièce simplement vous êtes devant la
tombe du guerrier squelette qui évite
les lidd comment l'avez vous gardiez
n'est pas dans cette pièce là vous êtes
juste vous seul libre en armes debout
exactement dans les positions que vous
avez dans cette hallucination collective
et à l'endroit précis où vous êtes dans
l'hallucination collective
vous êtes vraiment en parallèle en train
de faire les déplacements dans le monde
réel peut pas reculer pourquoi c'est
peut-être la déesse du talia qui vous
protège sait pas exactement ce qui se
passe mais quoi qu'il arrive garder ça
en tête
vous êtes exactement au même endroit la
vision se trouble et disparaît et vous
n'être que dans la vision de
l'hallucination donc on est de retour
avec verdi verdine séparer veillant est
d'accord
le seul impact qu'on a eu c'est que ça
s'est troublée et qu'on était au même
endroit que tout à l'heure dernier
n'était pas avec nous dans l'autre
endroit
ok donc on est coincé quand même pas
conseil bah oui on va redescendre mais
oui ces foires en gros voilà en gros ce
ya dans toutes les autres salles dans
cette famille attend attendait attend
quelque chose il ya dorine pendant
quelque chose quoi mais non je n'entends
rien de ce pays la première rom en cinq
épisodes
j'ai envie de lancer un dé lance un des
bassins d faut que je fasse un ou plus
ou trois ans et que celle des sur lequel
tu peux faire 0-0 temps des craquements
venant de la porte que vous avez bloqué
tout à l'heure a priori elle ne devrait
pas tarder à céder c'est grâce à toi
conte à cette information d'accord et
c'est bon tu n'en dormirais je
descendais donc vous descendez les
escaliers vous pénétrez de plus en plus
profondément titre vous suivez les vous
suivez l'escalier vous retomber dans la
grande salle d'immenses et ovales
d'environ 10 mètres de long non c'est
beaucoup plus simple madame étant en
fait il ya pas de fresques à la place d
un petit crépi blanc comme tu sais le
reconnaître c'est bien peu spécialiste
des crédits c'est c'est pourtant la
salle dont vous vous souvenez vraiment
avoir vu toutes les fresques et toute
l'histoire d'alice terre avec un
pédiluve au centre mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est également dans cette
salle que vous aviez découvert la
formule censée vous protéger de
l'influencé de la dormeuse les visions
se superposent pour envoyer les fresques
vous renvoyez les gobelins complètement
carbonisé dans la salle pour envoyer les
magnifiques fresques qui assure les murs
vous ne voyez pas verdier il n'est
toujours pas présent avec vous dans la
réalité et vous êtes exactement position
habituelle est-ce que will be sera
brûlant
à ce moment précis les villageois en
furie en furie barricades
9h10 poser l'avocate de miers vous
éclater tout ça il fonce sur vous il se
précipite vers la salle des fresques aux
qu'est ce que vous faites
une chose est sûre pour notre ami
magicienne c'est que le corps existe il
est toujours quelque part est sûrement
au fond du sanctuaire ok n'oubliez pas
que là je vous explique sa lentement
mais les villageois sont en train de
foncer dessus vous déballez démarche
poursuivie par les villageois en furie
dans vous entendez décrit furieux après
une descente qui vous semblent interne
et d'un interminable l'escalier débouche
sur une plateforme vous avez le
sentiment de vous être profondément
enfoncés dans le rocher de père devant
vous s'ouvre un gouffre énorme sivas que
vous n'en distinguer ni le fonds ni la
voûte à peine à percevez-vous par delà
le vide
notre plateforme accessible par un
antique de rennes donc à un bond sean un
peu dégueulasse qui s'étend au dessus de
la barre je te laisserai pas et qu'il
est un peu dégueulasse ce qu'il est
vraiment bien faire il est prêt en
juillet même des planches qui sont
cassés ouais mais je voulais qu'on
respecte ton dessin voilà les noms
dessinée très bien et des repères tu
sais quoi
walker ni s'approche un bouton et y
reçoit un vertige l'espace derniers
instants du coup je reçus
7 sept ok tu ressembles merci pour
l'engouement futur sent qu'il ya une
espèce de magie qui fait que le pont en
fête ne peut pas se détériorer dans le
temps qu'il a cette vision un peu
cradingue mais qu'en fait il ne peut
être que maintenu et se détériore pas
réellement avec le temps vous y allez
pendant quelques secondes à peine le la
superposition ce l'euro fait alors que
là d'autres voient sûrement pensé oh mon
train derrière moi j'imagine oui et vous
voyez dans la réalité en train de
traverser vous voyez qu'effectivement le
pont est intacte et qu'il est
complètement solide vous avancez sur le
pont la vision disparaît vous êtes
heureux sur cette nouvelle vision de
pont prêt à céder et derrière vous il ya
verdier qui s'engagent en dernier juste
en gestion du dernier des villageois
arrive vraiment sur lui ils savent où
ils seront en berne où elle fait allez-y
sans moi
en effet je vais les retenir tant que je
peux ok t'es pas un personnel pauvre
poupe
il aura d'ailleurs des vous ne passerez
[Applaudissements]
à l'autre plateforme vous découvrez un
nouveau couloir un peu plus large qui
peut être fermé par une porte vous
passez la porte et vous découvrez
quelques même par une lourde poutre
extrêmement solide
ok tu veux vous fermez là permettez la
poudre sur le pont verdier tente tant
bien que mal d'empêcher le passage des
villageois en faisant de larges moulinet
avec sa masse ok bon bref toi tu fais de
la grs verdier jeu que ce soit toi mais
hier c'est un peu court séjour ils ont
menacé j'aurais eu la poutre mais ce
deuil vous ça crie et regarde vers la
voûte une rumeur sinistre rempli la
grotte à gigantesque état et est un
gigantesque et sa de chauves-souris
émergent des ténèbres et sainte-marie là
vous voyez le pauvre verdier dans un cri
de terreur s'est recroquevillé sur
lui-même avant d'être happé par un
grillage démarche mineuse vous refermé
la porte et vous dites ça fait pas si
peur que ça qu'on les voit quand même
déplacé la poutre horrifié par cette
dernière vision désormais vous êtes seul
face à la sorcière dormantes
le coureur débouche sur une salle
circulaire elle est vide et comporte de
nombreux d'issue possible la première
vers l'est alors là va falloir me dire
un petit peu où vous allez et tout va se
faire en fonction d'eux
il est tout beau analyser peut-être du
petit courant d'air qui dirait qu'elle
le public peut-être décider exactement
les connaît ils disent n'importe où via
le tunnel 1-2-3 lever la main ce qu'ils
veulent qu'ils aillent dans le
introduire des réfléchissez la main
numéro un le numéro deux et la numéro
trois c'est le roder le vote le plus nul
de l'histoire on ne sait même pas lequel
est des trajets l'autre nous avons élu
de manière démocratique et nous irons au
bout du problème on va en continu avant
cette madame précautionneuse et ont fini
par déboucher sur un truc à force
exactement et en arrivant dans cette
salle au bout vous vous rendez compte
qu'il y à un gobelin qui fort
heureusement que vous a pas entendu
arriver vous avez été assez discret il
ya un train on est en train de monter la
garde à qu'est ce que vous faites les
amis ok tu me fais un g et tu me dis le
résultat en est elle si ce jeu va le
choper par surprise du coup est ce que
tu peux me refaire un g s'il te plaît
tu arrives et a couru derrière da couru
t'as pas tomber vraiment a été hyper
pense pas qu'ils soient tombés laquelle
deux épaules mains jambes a sauté comme
souvent la risée rien avec ton ep tout
est parti pour la porter c'est bien si
ça pouvait pas contenté d'envoyer au
ralenti j'ai la foi et garonne n'a pas
touché un plus bas de g ainsi d'arriver
sur lee mais vraiment il s'est retourné
à la dernière seconde et il a esquivé
comme ça d'un petit fait aussi et lui
d'ailleurs en esquivant c'était rigolo
savoir s'il tombe pas et ne s'est pas
vous le savez nous avons des sentiments
il a fait son petit saut comme ceci donc
toi tu es face à lui lui et face à toi
vous êtes encore tous derrière j'ai
regardé on a regardé ouais on était au
combat du coup du coup c'est que je suis
en même temps j'y reviendrai pas le roc
a fella l'a20 sinon donnez moi un
couteau et le guen moi j'ai des coups de
moins bien sûr je sais que je
réfléchisse en termes d'initiatives lui
vient de faire ça donc pour l'instant
c'est vous qui déterminez vos actions et
donc du coup je précédent oui je propose
qu'on seront face aux caméras
l'épisode 4 mai
[Applaudissements]
à
désolé il est pas malade il n'est pas
validé kaméaméha n'a jamais été versées
avant d'être envoyés comme ça ultime
essai by par pas là ils peuvent rester
là c'est là que tu te concentres et en
septembre à tout bon sens dix habitants
vous avez des fleet détruire le peu de
carrière que j'ai entendu c'est un piège
aussi du cabinet toulouse ou autres
nations elle avait juste derrière pour
la justice aille au quatuor s'est
[Applaudissements]
autoproclamé derrière comme ça tu n'as
qu'à je suis tranquille tu la
fabrication voilà un petit peu de
trois-quarts final c'est papa quand ils
me voient tata sûr il n'y a pas de
caméras mais qui soit
année
[Applaudissements]
à l'applaudimètre
non
et elle arrive sur le gobelin qui se
prend pour une blessure dont il est la
blessure une blessure il faut les faire
douce blessure pour le tuer du coup une
intention mais occupez vous de votre
action
j'attends un mas de guerre j'en garde
matériel mais en plus un certain au mas
de guerre n'est pas un projectile by
mésaventure ne pourra pas de l'envoyer
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial c'est qu'hier c'était une
autre il ya beaucoup trop dur ton jeu un
gobelin et la semos finale
alors oui tu décoche des flèches
ok ça c'est déjà pas mal est ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle touche elle touche hélas
aux caisses le couple a en caisse le
deuxième des cas voyez maintenant n'ont
pas de nouvelles
j'ai rien qui a été introduite est
contre lui à pas le toucher
donc vous venez de goûter à gobelins
juste ici vous avez la possibilité de
trois au tunnel vous prenez lequel
attend et ça je pense qu on a été faire
là dedans ces mutins comme la veille à
rien d'autres après lui non il gardait
rien larry monter la garde
pourquoi est ce que vous prenez la
sortie porte d'orléans hors de forme de
clients coureurs de clients entre courts
ou strasbourg samedi cornet a écrit en
cours je vais aller avec lui deux
installations porte de clignancourt
vous prenez la porte de clignancourt
ok vous avancez dans le tunnel un
prévisionnel et vous arrivez au bout de
ce tunnel à une autre lourde de doubles
portes à double et là vous vous dites on
a été très malin je pense qu'on vient
d'éviter de se perdre dans un dédale
ou alors cette partie est en accéléré
mais on aimerait bien et beaucoup plus
long si vous êtes et faire vous même
mais vous arrivez à une double porte
très très lourde
est-ce que vous ouvrez fait fort oui ok
ouvre la porte ouvre toi oui toi titre
oui on est d'accord ok tu te retrouves
dans une salle d'environ 4 mètres sur 4
mètres on est plutôt sur quelque chose
de carré savoir
que j'ai déjà vu l'écart est d'ailleurs
de doc seven qu'est ce que t'as quelque
part en géométrie toi cette salle est
décorée de nombreux symboles vous en
déplacer plusieurs pour bloquer la porte
je conçois et placé seul à ce moment là
on également qu'une phrase on assure une
petite coquille et bien vous vous vous
en déplacer plusieurs très bien à bas
ces symboles jours des mois j'ai besoin
d'une phrase de l'auteur dessinateur il
ya des statuts non à l'humiliation
parce que ça fait longtemps face à bout
un nouveau couloir s'ouvre et s'enfonce
dans l'obscurité au dessus de son entrée
sur une plaque de marbre car vous
distinguer deux yeux fermés sculpté en
bas relief et de la cor de chasse le
couloir débouche une vaste salle deux
miss ferrique arrêt de lumière tombe du
plafond vers une sorte de plateforme
surélevée tout au centre accessible par
quelques marches la lumière tombe droit
sur un autel donc au sens exact des
barriques
laguë pas hyper drôle mais habité lequel
et je parle bien toujours de l'hôtel
sont sculptés des éperviers et plusieurs
représentations d'alistair soufflant
dans un corps mais point de corps sur
l'autel vous sembliez alors hante encore
allégés rires moqueurs venue de l'une
par vous détourner votre attention de
l'hôtel pour examiner les alentours
d'autres villageois sont présents comme
endormi un peu partout sur le sol
parmi les statues de guerriers posés à
même le sol enfin vous remercier vous
remarqué et vous remercie mr iriez vous
remarqué que les parois de la salle dans
la partie ouest sont minés par de
nombreuses galeries vous constatez alors
avec horreur que des dizaines d'yeux
vous observent depuis c'est une des
gobelins au point de bonus alors trois
heures le nord doit se réveiller
le maire demandera des hommes après que
tu le dis le dormeur doit se réveiller
vous entendez notre ami semaine la
prononcer cette vois tu cette phrase à
haute voix le dormeur doit se réveiller
un mouvement de surprise parcours
l'assemblée des gobelins tandis que se
superpose le rêve et la réalité presque
identique à cri de colère résonne vous
vous tourner vers la plateforme est
constaté que le corps est bien là dans
le monde réel il existe n'oubliez pas
que vous êtes aussi physiquement là
ouais
c'est pour ça débarrassé des illusions
projetée par la sorcière il est
simplement posé sur l'autel puis la
vision s'effacer le corps disparaît mais
vous savez qu'il est toujours là à
portée de marley que vous n'avez plus
qu'à le saisir
que faites vous on tâtonne à l'endroit
où les sens et non tu n'es pas encore
sur le thé le thé à l'entrée de la salle
on va dans l'hôtel vite à peine à peine
notre ami célia tel commencé à poser le
pied sur les marches de l'hôtel de glace
se lance à sa poursuite
vous atteignez tous rapidement les
marches à vis de vous emparer de l'arti
fight qui seule pourra pas l'être
j'ai pas dis feuilles je veux dire la
défaite
bonsoir marc marti fait non je déconne
racheter fait vous atteignez rapidement
les marches à vis de vous emparer de cet
objet si précieux qui s'il pourra sauver
servier vous même
mais dd première marche franchie vous
buter sous les 1 contre un mur de force
invisible qui vous empêchent d'avancer
vous sentez la puissance conques de la
dormeuse tous les acteurs on la sent
bien
vous sentez la puissance vraiment que tu
peux pas ne pas y penser
la dormeuse qui vous écrase et tentent
de s'emparer de votre esprit
dans un instant
la verdure dans un instant les gobelets
seront sur vous que faites vous attendez
je sais on va mettre une coupure pub qui
vient de passer du bien parce à la wayne
je savais pas trop compris que c'est
alors que faites-vous sinon je sais
beaucoup d'argent je veux commencer
vas-y allez donc toi tu dois tu n'as
aucun bonus n'est en vigueur néo volonté
donc il faut qu'ils fassent leur font
plus rien oui il a fait 9
alors pendant ce temps là on a beaucoup
de chance parce que les gobelins avance
que très lentement vers l'est qu'ils ont
ainsi on peut se permettre que vous
essayez touche de rentrer dans
l'escalier dit au quai des marques fille
vous êtes deux à réussir à avancer en
continu les couples à se rapproche très
lentement on sait pas pourquoi mais il
arrive que l association des pilotes
cette rien ok tous les trois vous êtes
bien avancé vous deux vous propose de
préparer votre défense au cas où les
gobelins ça fait des tournées ok oui
merci aux dix chefs locaux
tu prépares tu as aidé dans ses mollets
donne toujours tout en dessous d'un
alors que célia s'était avancé là où
personne ne s'est avancé avant m
je dégaine une femme se matérialise au
dessus de l'autel vraiment charte au
dessus c'est la donne alors tu reconnais
la créature qui vous avez fait fuir elle
se tient devant toi en lévitation ses
cheveux et les plis de sa robe d'une
rançon et sony fort mais non on habille
les plis de sa robe ondulant sous
l'effet d'une force dont tu ne peut
discerner l'origine ses bras tendus vers
toi sont marqués par le fort un rictus
déforme les traits de son visage et tu
sens le mur ce soit puisse encore de
nantes
derrière allez on continue on essaie je
bosse annonce yves dumas s'est vite fait
en mettant le boss tu passes mais c'est
quand même parce qu'on trouve à semaine
qui passe c'est bon tu sais si besoin
était ouais ok ça sent vraiment la fin
du film le personnage principal parti de
la voûte de la salle se détache alors
c'est passé vers la filière glacial est
mort il ya des éboulis de partout tous
les gobelins ce recul et ont peur comme
ça
heureusement il a été extrêmement proche
de vous allez vous toucher donc on a
vraiment chaud toi tu viens d'atteindre
l'hôtel que fais tu je ne suis pas sûr
de vouloir me marier alors je suis face
à la dormeuse la sorcière normande
elle avait en lévitation au dessus de
l'autel ya l'hôtel que devant toi tu
fais du jeu je tape je tâtonne là où
devrait être le corps dans le monde réel
ok je sens quelque chose je crois décide
pas de type d'action voilà je fais ça
déjà à ce qui est ce que je sens quelque
chose non tu sens rien de spécial à bas
jeudi le dormeur doit se réveiller lors
de la vision tout superpose avec la
réalité tu vois exactement je voulais
voir le corps je mets la main dessus
ok est ce que je le sens oui enfin dans
les couilles tu as la main dessus dans
le monde réel est super bon d'accord je
souffre dedans souffle le son grave et
profond du corps dans la grande chambre
de la norme store aussi vous aussi vous
renvoie aussitôt suivi d'un cri
déchirant la dormeuse vous jette un
regard des crédules ont fait semblent
souffler par la puissance du corps
réduit également le corps de la dame
qu'on qu'elle apparaisse au sol en robe
le truc paul a tué d'un coup immédiat le
rêve se dissipe
vous êtes revenu pour de bon dans le
véritable esparbié ahuri paniquer les
gobelins survivants vêtus de simples
hard et dépenaillé d'étals sans demander
leur reste et fuit dans les tunnels par
lequel il était arrivé
votre raison chancellent et vous mettez
un genou à terre le temps de remettre
vos idées en place et vous constatez que
vous êtes libérés de l'emprise de la
dormeuse la chambre est éclairé par un
rayon de lune filtrant par la brèche de
voûte déjà entre les sarcophages les
villageois commencent à se réveiller
hagard conclusion c'est quand même que
c'est veille
le plus débile dans toute cette série
parce que quand on était en pause lavage
ne se dit bon moi j'ai envie de crever à
la fin il faut quelques personnages qui
meurt et en fait les défauts je suis à
la passe et mes projets je suis pour
rien mais j'avais envie d'une symphonie
tennis bd évidemment là vous pouvez
commencer à vous occuper de tous les
villageois sauver un petit peu tout le
monde
puis vous donner le temps de contempler
la scène et prenez conscience de la
dureté de l'épreuve subie par la
population desservie et de l'état de
faiblesse et de dénuement dans lequel il
se trouve que regarde le dénuement le
plus total
perdu dans vos pensées vous être rejoint
par verdier
il est donc vivant visiblement bien
marqué par ce qu'il a vécu yossef le via
les acolytes de mme haidar s'approche
également de vous et avec peine c'est
miraculeux d'imaginer que le vieux
d'âcre diacre ses titres ces miraculés
d'imaginer que le vieux tiac les plus
sûres
[Musique]
à nouveau nous vous devons bong est un
peu mixé avec le père fouras grand jeu
nous vous devons une fière chandelle
petits schtroumpfs soupire le sergent
d'assez sergent au plus vite sans vous
cette chose aurait fini par tous nous
tuer donc il vient de vous dire ça dans
l'un des sarcophages d'ailleurs qui a à
côté que vous avez réussi à ouvrir
pendant votre opération de sauvetage
vous avez découvert une petite fille de
13 ans j'appelle solène risques et
l'émouvant nous cherchons pas un
tournant
tout à fait non elle a pleuré à chaudes
larmes en vous voyant vous a beaucoup
remercier elle était très très affaiblie
comme les autres à l'été un prise en
charge par d'am-dam isolde qui vont
elles aussi de serre et de services pour
l'instant vous l'avez pas recroiser en
tout cas mais ça on peut être aller
moins bien c'est vrai et les ja de sève
qui ne vient vous voir et qui dit vous
savez les victimes parce que lui a plu
du tout la bo du grand show à wil a
perdu volé par berliet vous explique que
les victimes sont tout de même très
nombreuses j'ai bien peur que mon bon
maître mec d'art ne soit plus de ce
monde
personne ne l'a vu ici il ya fort à
parier qu'il ait fait partie des
premières victimes
de même dans notre chauvine hélas nous
avons subi des pertes mais beaucoup ont
survécu et au mois sept chose est mort
désormais grâce à vous you cet attrape
le bras du sergent stupéfait par cette
déclaration morte comment vous savez
qu'elle est morte
la sorcière dormantes puis se tournant
vers vous il ajoute et vous vous croyez
vraiment qu'elle est morte parce qu'au
fond de moi c'est vraiment que ça va se
terminer comme ça il le joue comme ça
oui tout à fait j'ai le coeur qui
palpite
alors heureusement la vie doit reprendre
son cours vous allez aider un petit peu
tout le monde dans cette suite un peu
imaginaire vous allez même passé
à vous reposer vraiment dans un indien
de show demandent à pouvoir monter on va
soigner ses blessures on va penser tout
ça et le lendemain vous retrouvez
verdier yossef qui coordonne les
opérations de soins des blessés
quand vous les rejoignent et il ya alia
qui hélas celle dont vous avez retrouvé
la fille juste de l'équité quoi de
partir et il ya eu cette dit la pauvre
femme elle a perdu la tête depuis
qu'elle a perdu sa fille à c'est là que
vous lui répondez étonné mais ne vous
l'avons retrouvé sa fille solenn quand
on a libéré tout le monde annonce et
repose et on est reparti dans un univers
parallèle
non attendez on s'est endormi non pour
la pub je peux tu le dit jean bridge ok
impossible répond ben youssef vous devez
vous impossible répond verdier je vous
devez vous prendre pour youssef de la
vente par l'ua c'est à l'hôpital
impossible vous dis verdier vous devez
forcément vous trompez il n'y a pas de
solaire il appela pauvre petit est morte
de maladie il ya plus de dix ans elle
avait à peine trois ans si je me
rappelle bien et ça réduit sa mère
complètement folle ainsi s'achève sa
cinquième équipe
bon
et l'information évidemment c'est dans
cinq épisodes y aura que cinq épisodes
sur la chaîne mais vous avez bien
compris qu'un sixième potentiel qui est
prêt il est sur le facebook de l'auteur
des scénarios françois les vins je vous
mets un lien dans la description vous
pouvez aller télécharger le sixième
c'est bien sûr ton facebook 1 vous
pouvez aller je télécharger vous pouvez
aller télécharger le sixième scénario
soit pour le jouer ce qui est beaucoup
mieux soit juste pour le lire si vous
voulez savoir aussi mais pas le jouer ce
sera encore plus sympathique voilà merci
beaucoup à françois d'avoir été présent
avec nous à ce que les taux des trois
taxes
merci à ces ménages c'est d'avoir six
victoires à zéro avec sun
[Applaudissements]
les chaînes sont dans la description
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner merci à
tout public est venu c'était vraiment
ouf et cool que vous soyez là ça me
donne envie de monter plein d'autres
projets comme ça en public et que vous
sachiez des couacs
on essaiera de faire ça sur des jours un
peu plus c'était vraiment un gros qui
forme agence pour vous aussi merci
d'avoir été dispo à chaque fois pour
tous ces tournages étaient très nombreux
voilà j'ai travaillé sur un autre
scénario 17 épisodes savez
[Applaudissements]